What makes someone a hero?
There is never just one answer to that question.
Some will tell you that it’s selflessness,
putting other people before oneself that makes
someone heroic.
Others believe that heroism takes someone
with a clear sense of morality, the ability
to tell right from wrong with absolute certainty.
Perhaps a hero should also be a symbol, a
paragon of hope and virtue for all of society
to look up to and aspire to be.
And then there are those who would argue that
a person can’t possibly be a hero, unless
they possess one key trait.
Whether that comes as the result of a freak
accident, gamma radiation exposure, or mutated
genes, being blessed with extraordinary powers
and the will to use them for good might just
be what elevates a moral, selfless and symbolic
hero into something more.
A superhero.
It is rare that the SCP Foundation encounters
an anomalous creature or entity that it considers
to be harmless.
There are, of course, exceptions, but perhaps
even more of a rarity is an SCP that seeks
to go out of its way and use its anomalous
abilities to do good.
So many of the creatures and entities kept
contained by the Foundation have malicious
intent, like damage-regenerating reptiles
with contempt for humanity and eldritch beings
with desires to take over this dimension.
But then there is SCP-2800, or as he prefers
to call himself, “Cactusman, the Spiked
Menace.”
Partially human, and part succulent plant,
SCP-2800 is one of a rare breed of SCPs: one
that aims to help people, rather than killing
them, enslaving them, or wiping reality as
we know it from existence.
And you might be surprised to learn that this
superhero known as Cactusman, began life as
one Daniel MacIntyre, an average guy from
Scotland.
Little is known about Daniel’s “origin
story.”
All superheroes have one, of course, but as
far as Foundation researchers are aware, Cactusman
wasn’t jettisoned in a pod from his dying
homeworld to the safety of Earth.
It is also safe to assume he didn’t get
pricked by a radioactive cactus, or have his
DNA infused with a plant during a genetic
experiment.
He was first encountered by the SCP Foundation
whilst they were trying to contain another
SCP, a reality warping object that had somehow
breached containment.
What Foundation staff tracking the object
witnessed was Cactusman attempting to assault
the escaped SCP, to little success.
Following this encounter, Foundation personnel
convinced Cactusman to allow them to contain
him.
He complied, was designated as SCP-2800, and
researchers began investigating the nature
of this strange, would-be superhero.
According to Daniel, one day his powers just
“happened”, with little understanding
as to how, why, or what had caused the transformation.
When asked about how he acquired his powers
during an interview with SCP Foundation researcher
Dr L'oeuf, Daniel said:
“To be honest, doc, I dunno.
I woke up one day, and boom, cactus powers.
Thought that I might as well use them for
good, right?
I always grew up reading a lot of comic books.
Always loved the X-Men as a little kid, so
I thought I was one of them.
Heh.
I thought I was the luckiest guy in the world,
ending up with superpowers.
Doesn't every kid wish that they could be
a superhero?”
Analysis by Foundation research staff revealed
that Daniel’s DNA had somehow merged with
a genome of a Carnegiea gigantea plant, or
saguaro cactus.
This plant is usually what most people picture
if they were to imagine a typical cactus,
and is known to be native to the Sonoran Desert,
as well as the Mexican state of Sonora.
How one became a part of Daniel McIntyre’s
genetic makeup is baffling.
It seems highly unlikely that a saguaro cactus
would grow naturally in Scotland, given that
the country has a far damper and colder climate
than the scorching hot deserts that saguaros
normally thrive in.
Regardless of exactly how Daniel became fused
with a cactus, his body shares a number of
the same physical properties of the plant.
Pointed spines protrude from his skin, which
can grow to just over an inch in length.
It seems that SCP-2800 can either remove these
spikes manually with little pain, or will
eventually shed them naturally over time,
allowing more to regrow in their place.
As well as outwardly looking like an anthropomorphic
cactus, SCP-2800 also shares various biological
traits with his cacti counterparts.
Daniel’s body no longer functions in the
same way as that of an ordinary human being
in a number of different ways.
Firstly, he is able to perform photosynthesis,
deriving the necessary nutrients he requires
from direct sunlight.
This negates the need for him to consume any
food, and prevents him from feeling hunger
or the fatigue this can often bring.
Additionally, his altered biology allows Cactusman
to store more water than would normally be
possible for the average human.
And he requires less of it too.
SCP-2800 is able to keep himself hydrated
with a third of the required fluids for an
average person.
Daniel can also adapt to more arid environments,
with drier climates and above average levels
of heat having little impact on his abilities.
Speaking of abilities, SCP-2800 is not just
a man with the physical and biological traits
of a saguaro cactus - he also has superpowers
that seem, well let’s say inspired by a
cactus.
While perhaps not as flashy as being faster
than a speeding bullet, more powerful than
a locomotive, or able to leap tall buildings
in a single bound, Cactusman does possess
his own unique set of superhuman abilities.
Derived, like his other traits, from his part-saguaro
DNA, SCP-2800 has the power to empathically
communicate with other plant life.
Unlike telepathy and the ability to communicate
solely through thoughts, empaths like Cactusman
are able to influence or interpret the emotions
or moods of others, so similar but a little
more subtle in its effectiveness.
Cactusman might have superhuman powers, altered
DNA, and a mysterious origin, but another
part of a hero’s journey is their struggle
and SCP-2800 is no exception to this either.
Despite his desire to do good, he harbors
a lot of unrest under that prickly exterior.
After extensive psychological examination
by the researchers at the SCP Foundation,
Daniel was diagnosed with two distinct mental
disorders.
The first of these is dysthymia, or chronic
depression, with the other being a condition
colloquially known as “hero syndrome.”
Hero syndrome, as its name suggests, is often
characterized by an unstoppable, pathological
urge to help other people, usually ignoring
any risks to oneself in the pursuit of assisting
even total strangers.
Some with this disorder will even attempt
to manufacture dangerous scenarios in order
to act like the hero, and earn themselves
recognition and praise for reacting heroically
to the danger they secretly caused.
Like committing arson so they can save people
from a burning building.
SCP-2800 has never attempted anything like
this so far, but Cactusman does express an
extreme willingness to help people, and try
to intervene in any situation that he thinks
he can assist with.
The problem is, SCP-2800 is hardly an experienced
crimefighter, and this has put him on the
receiving end of his fair share of injuries.
During his first outing as “Cactusman, the
Spiked Menace”, Daniel encountered a group
engaging in the sale of illicit substances
and attempted to apprehend them.
While he was able to deal a cactus-spine-filled
blow to one of their faces, the group quickly
overpowered Cactusman and beat him until local
law enforcement arrived to save him.
Determined to prove himself a hero, though,
Daniel returned to patrolling the streets
soon after, but met the same result.
Even weak, petty criminals seemed like they
were too much for Cactusman to handle.
While his hero syndrome compels SCP-2800 to
want to do good and set a good example, it
is also directly linked to his other condition:
His dysthymia.
By attempting and failing to be heroic, Cactusman
becomes chronically depressed, yet still has
the urges brought on by his hero syndrome
to put himself in harm’s way for the sake
of others.
And when he is unable to provide help, Daniel
falls back into depression.
It’s a very difficult cycle.
In the hopes of counteracting some of Daniel’s
struggles, the SCP Foundation have gifted
him a pair of potted cacti.
These occupy SCP-2800’s cell with him, both
oxygenating his room as well as boosting his
morale.
Although, he has remarked that cacti don’t
say much to him beyond “I'm thirsty” and
“I am a cactus”, Daniel has affectionately
named his potted plants.
They’re now known as Cactilad and Spikigirl,
his sidekicks in the never ending battle against
evil.
During interviews with Foundation researcher
Dr L'oeuf, Daniel admitted that he was the
victim of bullying throughout much of his
childhood.
From a young age he often found himself in
physical altercations with bullies that singled
him out and picked on him at school.
Cactusman said that his experiences encouraged
him to “give back”, and that despite having
suffered at the hands of bullies, it made
SCP-2800 determined to help others in need.
In his own words, Daniel didn’t want what
had happened to him to happen to anybody else
and it is highly likely that these experiences
from his youth are at least part of the cause
of his hero syndrome.
However, another incident may also be linked
to SCP-2800’s condition.
Despite not often prevailing against petty
criminals, there is CCTV surveillance footage
of Cactusman from before his containment by
the SCP Foundation.
The footage in question was taken at a subway
close to where Daniel “patrolled” and
looked for criminals to apprehend.
In the surveillance tape, a woman and her
child can be seen waiting at the subway station
near a support pillar.
From behind the pillar, an assailant in a
mask appeared, wielding what looked to be
a knife.
The woman, cowering and trying to protect
her child, was made to open her purse, as
the attacker threatened her with his knife.
But then, Cactusman appears behind the man.
He walked up to him and punched him in his
lower back and chest.
A number of SCP-2800’s sharp cacti spines
end up lodged in the man’s skin, causing
him to drop his knife in pain.
During the ensuing scuffle, SCP-2800 was able
to tie the man up, thus saving the woman and
her child.
The woman then thanked Cactusman, shaking
his hand and embracing him.
Her child also expressed gratitude, with SCP-2800
kneeling down to face them and appearing to
get emotional at receiving recognition.
After signing an autograph for the child,
Cactusman then disappeared from the scene
before police arrived.
Cacti have the tenacity to grow in barren
desert environments, surviving on very little
water.
It is for that reason, that to some, these
plants have come to symbolize strength, resilience,
and endurance.
This one encounter captured in this surveillance
footage may well have been one of the few
times Cactusman ever succeeded at being heroic,
but perhaps it is all he needed to encourage
him to keep trying.
To seek out wrongdoings time and time again,
even if it led to him being injured.
Maybe knowing that just once he had succeeded
in saving a woman and her child, was enough
to convince him that he would one day be able
to do so again.
And maybe that is what makes someone a true
hero: The power to endure.
Now check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“SCP-096 - The Shy Guy” for more anomalies
that have the power to endure in spades!